good morning well i think it's important
to cautiously
support our businesses who've really
struggled over the last 60 months and
here on the roof garden of john lewis in
oxford street
haven't used the tube to get here we've
got to recognize is particularly in
hospitality
in culture in the nighttime economy in
retail
this businesses have really really
struggled we shouldn't just
abandon all the things we've learned
over the last 60 months that's one of
the reasons why
on public transport in london it is a
condition of courage it is the rules
you've got to wear a face mask because
we know the public health advice is very
simple
if you're a face mask it reduces the
chances of transmission so
when you can't keep your social distance
when you're indoors
we're a face mask but i think we should
be encouraging people to
safely uh you know enjoy culture enjoy
hospitality and enjoy retail
i think it's the first time i've spoke
to you for some months when you haven't
been wearing a mask
are you adapting your personal mask
wearing policy
i've got to be quite careful adam
because i'm such a good mood i'm in
danger of hugging people uh outdoors and
so
not only am i not wearing a face mask
when i'm outdoors safely like this but
i'm also tempering my own uh behavior
it's lovely i've got it to you it's just
nice seeing people it's nice being
outdoors
people i've not seen for some time
people i've got to i got to know over
the last 60 months never met in person
and so what i'd say to those watching is
it's fantastic news
that restrictions have been eased but
let's just be conscious of the fact
the virus is still here in london alone
on a daily basis
4 000 new cases thank goodness though
because of the high take-up of the jabs
the vaccines what we're not seeing
is massive increases in hospitals and
thankfully we're not seeing
death as well so messages if you've not
had the job yet please take the job
because the jabs are making a difference
you have though
laid down that people have got to wear
masks on public transport
would it have helped if the government
had said that that was the national rule
yeah it would have been it would have
been far far easier would have been
had the benefit of being clear and uh
obvious
if we had one set of rules for the
entire country i'm disappointed
they didn't but i welcomed the fact what
the government didn't do was
veto cities doing what they thought was
right that gave us the autonomy
to do what we think is uh right and
that's why in london because i've seen
the evidence from
the government's own advisors sage i've
studied the evidence from the world
health organization the center for
disease control and many others
i recognize that the evidence is quite
clear if you wear a face mask
indoors it reduces the chances of
transmission and for me it's an
additional layer
of both protection and reassurance so if
you want to use puppy transport in
london you must wear a face mask now i
don't know about john lewis but
i imagine they've got quite a lot of
staff for having to isolate at the
moment because they've been pinged or
identified as
having been in contact with someone who
tested positive do you think this this
pinging system which is now affecting
1.7 million people
is really necessary given that we do
have
on-the-spot testing available
i think the the pinging and the test and
traces affect not just essential
services
like transfer for london the nhs the
police the fire service but also have
businesses
particularly the small ones who may
employ 11 12 people and four or five are
out of action because they've been
pinged
uh and it's a big problem what i'd uh
what
i want the government to do is to look
into the possibility of bringing forward
the date
uh it's currently the 16th of august
after which you don't need to self
isolate if you've had both jabs
and you do a test what i do know is many
of us have now
both jabs and we may be pinged
but we've not got the virus and that's
why it's really important for the
government to look into
whether it's a proportional response now
we've had both jabs
uh particularly when we know for example
in london i can give you the news that
more than 10 million doses
have been administered of the jab more
than
75 of those above the age of 40 have had
both jobs
and so the response last year the right
response in relation to test and trace
was that was sensible but now bear in
mind many of us have had both jobs the
government should look into whether it's
a proportional response
and what they should bring forward the
16th of august to an earlier date
you've uh say been looking at the data
how do you feel about vaccinating the
under 18s about vaccinating school
children
i'm really looking forward to what the
jcvi say today
we've got to be guided by the science uh
bear in mind that the summer holidays
provides a really good
circuit breaker because children aren't
in the classrooms passing the virus on
we'd kick ourselves if we didn't use
that six weeks as an opportunity
to get young people particularly those
who are vulnerable having the
jab i'm guided by the science so let's
get into what the jcvi said
says if they say that it's safe and it's
the right thing to do and it helps
how younger people have in the job i
think we should make sure we work really
hard
over the six weeks to have as many young
people as possible who are suitable
who may be vulnerable getting the job so
in september what you don't see is the
disruption we've seen in the last term
finally away from covid obviously you
have responsibilities for transport in
london
what is your feeling now about
e-scooters we have seen
a number of fatalities both of people
riding them and people
not riding them they are very prevalent
in the city i thought they hadn't been
licensed yet what's going on
no so so they're unlawful they're
illegal they're very dangerous
uh the police service are trying their
best to enforce uh this
law it's a difficult law to enforce for
obvious reasons in some boroughs uh
there are six boroughs initially there
are now a couple more
uh they're piloting uh whether
e-scooters is the way forward
and in those boroughs you've got to go
to one of the companies that hire out
these scooters
the big advantage of that company is
you've got to have a license or
provision license
there's insurance and there are
safeguards in in place only if you go to
one of those boroughs
where you hire an e-scooter is it lawful
to do so in any other circumstance
you're breaking the law
and do you think it's like to stay like
that or will they just
become a fact of life like you know
bicycles and cars and motorbikes
one of the conundrums the government had
and this is why i support the pilot
system
is the genies out of the bottle many
people are buying east goods
as christmas presents and so i think
we've got to
be realistic they're here we're going to
make sure they're going forward
they are used only safely and that's why
we the boroughs joined the pilot scheme
to see how it worked out if it's the
case the pilot scheme shows
in fact you can't do it safely they're
dangerous there's no
response that is sensible then of course
they should continue to be
outlawed if it's the case the pilot
scheme works and there's a system found
where
it's possible to hire any scooter in a
safe way and it does
improve the quality of life of yourself
in relation to going through traffic
and not you know adding to the toxic air
that's something we can look into
the pilot system is a good system to use
to check whether something should be
made permanent or you know outlawed
altogether
and so the boroughs that are having the
pilots will wait and see
what they show